foreign
you got to take what you need when you
can get it you got to learn to stand up
for yourself you're gonna have to quit
being a puppy and kick these kids into
balls or something
or don't I don't care just leave me the
hell out of it now get on out of here
okay thanks Hannah
[Music]
foreign
to another extra special RT Essentials
rotten claws is in the hizzy that's
right we're back please please you can
remain seated hold your applause I hope
you like what I've done with the place
now normally I wouldn't spend so much my
time with the holiday decoration but I
couldn't help myself because this
episode's a little different we're
looking at The Not So Nice Santa's from
movies one you might even call naughty I
call them Heroes and dear friends from
just a little bit creepy and mean all
the way to the morally corrupt and even
murderous this list has something in its
red sack for everyone so let's load up
the sleigh spice up that eggnog I won't
be gone long and take a ride through our
list of naughty Santas in cinema history
Billy Bob Thornton Bad Santa
yes uh your performance you know the um
performers like sexual
excuse me Willie are you saying there's
something wrong with my gear
is that what you're saying to me I'm
sorry your gear Willie my stick
and kicking off this list is Billy Bob
Thornton from 2003's Bad Santa this dark
comedy was directed by Terry zweigoff of
Ghost World Fame and was executive
produced by none other than the Coen
Brothers Joe and Ethan and if Billy Bob
stars is the cranky Willy T Stokes who
poses as a mall Santa every year along
with his partner the elf played by Tony
Cox so they can pull a con and
eventually Rob all the stores on
Christmas Eve when we find Willie in
this film he's depressed and an
alcoholic and nearing Rock Bottom with
his erratic Behavior to make things more
complicated he ends up attracting the
attention of Mall Security Bernie Mac in
this case and also befriends a young boy
now the Badness of this Santa began with
an idea from the Coen brothers who
brought in writers Glenn ficara and John
rayqua to write what they thought was a
really crashed script until the cohens
went and crested up even more that
script was then rejected by Universal
who thought it was too foul and
disgusting which were pretty much the
exact reasons why Miramax did give it
the green light what's it like at the
North Pole like the suburbs which one
Apache Junction what the do you
care I get off my lap and sit there
you are really Santa right no I'm an
accountant I wear this thing as a
fashion statement all right
okay
Marcus get this kid out here to bring
this bad santa to Life actors like James
Gandolfini Bill Murray Jack Nicholson
and Robert De Niro were considered for
the role before Thornton was eventually
cast and to be truly authentic with the
character I'm sure Thornton has said
that he was genuinely intoxicated for
some of the filming he also said in his
autobiography that he could go back and
relive any time in his life making this
film was listed is that a coincidence
but if it's a bad santa you want it
mission accomplished an editorial in the
Washington Times called this movie the
evil twin of Miracle on 34th Street and
ripped Disney who owned Miramax at the
time for allowing a beloved figure like
Santa Claus to be portrayed like this
they probably aren't enjoying this
episode so far either and even more
raunchy unrated version called batter
Santa was released on DVD and a sequel
Bad Santa 2 came in 2016 with Billy Bob
and a handful of other cast members
returning Bill Goldberg Santa's sleigh
Santa
yes Virginia there is a Santa Claus and
going into the three count next on this
list is Bill Goldberg from the 2005 film
Santa's sleigh pro wrestler Goldberg
stars as Santa Claus in this Christmas
slasher comedy that was directed and
written by David Simon the premise of
this movie is that Santa Claus is
actually a demon who happened to lose a
bet with an Angel causing Santa to
become a gift-giving source of Joy but
he returns to his evil ways when the bed
is off and to really set the tone for
this naughty with just putting it
lightly Santa the opening scene features
the evil old elf coming down the chimney
to face a family that has been bickering
about material things and after starting
with the dog Santa proceeds to take out
the whole star-studded family including
names like Rebecca Gayheart and Chris
Kattan Santa even finds Christmas-themed
ways of doing his killing like drowning
Fran Drescher in a bowl of eggnog and
suffocating James con with a turkey leg
do it
despite only appearing in a handful of
films like Adam Sandler's The Longest
Yard and the Thriller half past Dead Two
Goldberg has made a career of putting on
convincing and physically dominating
performances in the wrestling ring and
Santa sleigh definitely gives a few nods
to that part of Goldberg's life as Santa
is doing his dirty work at one point he
attacks the owner of the Delhi by using
his signature wrestling move the spear
and he also delivers his trademark who's
next line during a post-credits scene
critic David nusair from real film
reviews said that Goldberg delivers an
appropriately tongue-in-cheek
performance and viewing his Santa Claus
with a nice balance of malevolence and
sleaziness but to counter at least some
of the naughty it's worth noting that
Goldberg met his future wife stun person
Wanda ferritin on the set of this film
oh it almost makes you forget that he
used the star on top of the tree as a
murder weapon Jim Belushi jingle all the
way for every little girl who left
cookies and milk for Santa on Christmas
night for every little boy who opens a
present Christmas morning and finds Club
it breaks my heart
there it is
I'll be 300.
dollars no chocolate kisses yes dollars
and jingling into the next spot on this
list is Jim Belushi from 1996's Jingle
All The Way directed by Brian Levant
from films like Beethoven and Snow Dogs
this movie was inspired by real life
Christmas time sellouts for toys like
Cabbage Patch Kids and Mighty Morphin
Power Rangers in the late 80s and early
90s the film stars Arnold Schwarzenegger
as a workaholic dad named Howard who
tries to make up for lost time with his
son by promising him the most sought
after toy of the Season turbo man the
hard to find toy ultimately takes him on
a wild adventure where he comes across a
mall Santa Con man played by Belushi
this naughty Santa brings Howard to a
warehouse filled with other con men
dressed in Santa suits who are making
get this counterfeit toys Belushi Santa
tries to sell Howard a cheaply made and
Spanish-speaking version of the toy with
pieces falling out of the box which
leads to a huge bra in the warehouse
that Howard narrowly escapes hear me
right con men thieves degenerates low
Labs thugs criminals
the North Pole of them are fighting
words partner put them up all right legs
buddy I'm not about to hit a Santa Claus
come on come on Woody
as it turns out Belushi who is also in
red heat and Last Action Hero with
Schwarzenegger was a great fit given his
real world experience as a naughty Santa
you see when he was in college he would
dress up as Santa to make money during
the holidays and once got arrested for
driving without a license while he was
wearing the suit and not far from a
school with plenty of young onlookers
Ricky Smiley Friday After Next the hell
you doing in my house eating a big
sandwich Santa Claus what a
American Cookies
let's get your ass out of here
finding just the right day of the week
next on this list is Ricky Smiley in
2002's Friday After Next this is the
third and final installment in the
Friday movie trilogy so far I was
directed by Marcus rayboy and written by
Ice Cube fossil Stars alongside Mike
Epps this time Epson cubes his character
Day Day and Craig are living back in the
old neighborhood from the first film
around the holidays a thief pressed his
Santa played by Smiley breaks into their
apartment and steals everything he can
fit into his red sack including the
guys's rent money along with the robbery
that sets up the whole premise of this
film Smiley Santa is also featured in
The climactic Chase through the
neighborhood scene at the end as well
both scenes include beatings done with a
Christmas tree and even though Smiley
used to stunt double for much of the
filming he did say later on that he got
the wind knocked out of him a couple
times from said tree beater
right there you crack baby
on top of that the comedian in radio
personality said that the chase scene
was filmed in a real nasty area and he
remembers laying on the ground looking
at maggots in the dirt underneath the
clothesline that's too gross even for
this Santa Smiley who would film in LA
and then fight back to Atlanta for his
other gigs only has a few film credits
for his career but he did work with
Cuban Epps in All About the Benjamins
earlier that same year although his
scene was ultimately cut but when you're
donning the red suit with a sack full of
goods like Smiley does in Friday After
Next there's no getting cut however he
did ultimately get caught
Jeff Gillen A Christmas Story
hurry up the stores are closing next up
on our list of naughty Santas of Cinema
is Jeff Gillen from 1983's classic A
Christmas Story the film was directed by
Bob Clark from movies like black
Christmas and porkies and is based on
film narrator Jean Shepard's
semi-fictional anecdotes from his 1966
book and other media taking place during
a midwest winter around 1940-ish this
one centers around the young Ralphie
Parker played by Peter Billingsley for
Christmas Ralphie wants nothing more
than an official Red Rider Carbine
action 200 shot Range model air rifle
and everywhere he turns like his mother
and his teacher Ralphie hears the same
thing you'll shoot your eye out and this
includes what has to be one of the most
frightening Santas it's ever appeared in
a family comedy the higbeast apartment
stores Santa played by Jeff Gillen his
performance comes complete with a unique
and terrifying ho ho ho which has no
doubt been burned into the minds of many
people over the years during his scene
Santa causes Ralphie to freeze up after
aggressively inquiring about what he
wants for Christmas and when Ralphie
finally drums up the courage to ask for
his BB gun Santa delivers the stock
warning of you'll shoot your eye out
before sending Ralphie down the slide
with his big Santa boot and one last ho
ho ho for good measure a football
what was I doing wake up stupid wake up
you'll shoot your eye out kid
Merry Christmas
Gillen who died in 1995 was an old
friend of director Bob Clark and had
appeared in some of his earliest films
including the dramony She-Man a story of
fixation and the horror movie Death trip
where Gillen served as Clark's assistant
director as well and besides my own
nightmares proved that this naughty
Santa had a lasting effect is that the
Higby store that was used for filming
kept the Santa slide that was made for
the film along with Santa's throne and
used them for many more years after the
movie's release Patton Oswalt a very
Harold and Kumar Christmas what do you
want for Christmas young man that's a
really good question I want a Snoopy
snow cone machine done in a DeLorean yes
I want the Wu-Tang to get back together
I'll tell the elves and by the way this
is just for my stockings okay for my
real present hey hey
leave me my sleigh in half an hour okay
you got it Merry Christmas Santa oh
right in the Sugar Plum coming in high
on this list and we're not talking about
the ranking is Patton Oswalt from 2011's
a very Harold and Kumar Christmas this
buddy Stoner comedy was directed by Todd
Strauss scholston and is the third
installment in the Harold and Kumar
franchise this time John chose Harold
and calpense Kumar have been estranged
but reunited to hunt for a valuable
Christmas tree after accidentally
burning down a similar one that belongs
to Harold's father-in-law but first to
help establish that this is indeed a
Christmas movie and that Kumar is still
you know Kumar he pays a visit to a mall
Santa played by Pat Oswalt who also just
so happens to be Kumar's weed dealer I
have Rudolph the red-eyed reindeer oh
it's a weederful life everything have to
be about Christmas
some people like the holidays yeah I had
some Hanukkah hash with the kids from
Temple Shalom Emanuel clean me out one's
a cookout well that's a little more
expensive this is like the Diwali dank
from October I'll take home hello
gentlemen
what do you have anything to smoke out
of after Kumar first visits Santa in his
element the character named Larry tells
Kumar to meet him by his sleigh in a
half hour that is of course his trunk
where Larry shows off numerous Christmas
inspired strains of marijuana and
because it is a Harold and Kumar movie
they then sample his products together
using what else Santa's Jolly Old Pipe
poisonotti Santa although considered
more naughty in some states than others
Oswald who would go on to voice a West
naughty Peter Rabbit for the animated
comedy series Santa Inc was extra
excited about the role of Santa after
learning it was going to be offered in
3D and no not because it would make him
look more Santa like or anything but
because he would describe this movie as
the first ever 3D exhilaration of pot
smoke on film those are career goals you
stuck the landing and we all need
something to Aspire to Robert Brian
Wilson Silent Night deadly night
oh this is
stirring
not even a mouse
creeping up next on this list is Robert
Brian Wilson from 1984's Silent Night
deadly night this psychological slasher
film was directed by Charles E cellular
Jr and stars Wilson as a young man named
Billy suffers from post-traumatic stress
after witnessing his parents being
murdered as a young boy on Christmas Eve
by a man in a Santa's suit that was
followed by an abusive upbringing in a
Catholic orphanage as a grown-up Billy
takes a job stocking shelves at a local
toy store after being forced to fill in
for the store's Santa Claus on Christmas
Eve Billy eventually snapped later that
night at the office Christmas party and
goes on a killing spree while dressed as
Santa of course
foreign
this marked the first ever roll for
Wilson who would go on to have recurring
roles and a couple soaps and guest spots
on a handful of TV shows before giving
up acting in the early 90s Wilson said
that the initial version of the film was
a bit too naughty for the npaa and it
eventually had to be submitted four
times just to get an R rating down from
X along with multiple Death Scenes being
shortened a nightmare sequence of Billy
being slashed by Santa was cut
altogether and while those cuts satisfy
the ratings people Silent Night deadly
night set off some serious controversy
in part because it's Killer's
santa-centric promos and the role of the
Catholic church in the movie because of
that it was pulled from theaters after a
week but still brought in a decent box
office haul since then has developed a
cult following and spawned a full-on
film series with four sequels a loose
remake in 2012 and a reboot currently in
the works once again top critic Matthew
rasa of salon.com said of this original
buried beneath the blood soaked Santa
suit Silent Night deadly night has
something a lot of slasher films lack a
unique identity
Dan Aykroyd Trading Places
this man's obviously a lunatic I'm
calling security
put that phone down
hello security
Merry Christmas
try to rob me plant drugs on me steal my
house my car my job you know I ought to
kill him right now next on our list of
naughty Santos of Cinema is Dan Aykroyd
from 1983's Trading Places the film was
directed by John Landis of Animal House
and Blues Brothers Fame and takes place
over several weeks leading up to and
after Christmas the film centers around
aykroyd's Lewis winthorpe and upper
level Finance exec and Eddie Murphy's
Ray Valentine a Down and Out Street
Hustler they become the subject of a bet
between winthorp's ritual bosses the
Dukes which leads to winthorpe being
framed for a crime and stripped of his
rich life which is then given to
Valentine in an attempt to clear his
name winthorpe dresses up as a not so
Queen version of Santa to get into the
firm's Christmas party there he
unsuccessfully tries to frame Valentine
by planting drugs in his desk and
ultimately brandishes a gun just to
escape Trading Places isn't your average
traditional Christmas movie but it's
themes regarding class were and are
still relevant and aykroyd's
progressively grows Santa suit helped
showcase a man who is falling to his
absolute Rock bot
[Music]
[Applause]
this was highlighted by an unforgettably
disgusting moment of him drunkenly
trying to eat a piece of salmon he
stuffed in his suit at the Christmas
party while on the bus ride home and
it's covered in his dirty Santa beard
hair ew the film was originally
developed as a project to Star Richard
Pryor and Gene Wilder who were hot
around that time as a Duo but Landis was
cool with the up-and-coming Murphy and
Aykroyd 2 after working with the latter
on The Blues Brothers and really it's
hard to imagine anyone other than
Aykroyd as this naughty salmon
Aficionado Santa especially after the
film earned over 90 million dollars to
become the fourth highest grossing film
of 1983. Paul Giamatti Fred Claus you
just keep stuffing your face with
Gingerbread Fatboy
you know I've been paddling away problem
for years friend that is not funny you
know what you can shove it thunder
thighs I'm sick of it this little tree's
gonna get some light Nick this little
tree's gonna chop that big tree down
your abuse and the final naughty Santa
on this list is Paul Giamatti from
2007's Fred Claus directed by David
Dobkin and written by Dan fogelman this
film is Loosely based on the poem a
legend of Santa and his brother Fred
written by Don Henkel Paul Giamatti
stars as Nicholas Claus who the actor
once described as a neurotic wreck and a
stressed out businessman who happens to
also be Santa Claus in Fred Claus Nick
decides to bail his jealous older
brother out of a jam by making him live
at the North Pole and help Santa in the
elves prepare for Christmas but when
Fred realizes that the Naughty Nice List
is being done all wrong and marks every
kid is nice Santa stress comes to a head
and he completely loses it the brothers
get into an epic snow fight for the ages
where this Santa officially earns his
naughty Stripes
come on Fat Boy
how'd you get to work today Nick did you
roll oh yeah did you steal a sled from
some little kid come on
back bye
good night sweet prince
Giamatti who said Edmund Gwen's Chris
Kringle from Miracle on 34th Street is
his favorite movie Santa spent roughly
two hours each day in the makeup chair
for his white hair and beard the fat
suit however only took a couple of
minutes to zip right into when it comes
to his performance Richard Probst from
the independentcritic.com said that
giamatti's seemingly inherent playful
morosiness adds a delightful Dimension
to the saintly Nick and it seems playing
a naughty Christmas figure suits
Giamatti well since he would go on to
play Scrooge in a series of Verizon
commercials recently well there you have
it a whole bunch of naughty Santas of
Cinema thankfully we've learned a few
things today most importantly the
Christmas decorations can also be used
as dangerous weapons but hopefully you
don't forget that Santa brings joy to a
lot of people all the time don't let a
handful of naughty ones ruin for the
rest of us you know because I'm one of
the good ones even though my name is uh
rotten claws so thanks for tuning in to
RT Essentials I've been your ho ho host
and we'll see you next time time for me
to get some lunch at oh no wait I still
got some salmon pocket
[Music]